Now let's talk about the solution to our problem with heat along the wire.
First things first, I've rewritten the implicit equation that I gave you in the intro video.
The only change here that you'll see is how I've replaced the coefficient
in front of the parenthesis with C, the parameter that we created for you in the code.
Now, if we rearranged this equation a little bit, we can get it in the form that's super convenient
for using numpy.matalg.solve.
This is because we already know T₈(0) and now we know what the coefficients are.
So we are to solve for all of the temperatures after times that of h.
This shows us then that two of the elements in the matrix coefficient
are going to be -C and 1+2C.
The one exception to this is going to occur at the boundaries.
I told you these were going to be a little bit tricky,
so let's talk about how to deal with them with right now.
We take this equation right here but instead plug in the correct values for T₀.
We see something interesting. There's a dependence on T₋₁.
Now we defined our boundary with additions earlier, that T₋₁ is going to equal T₀ for any time.
Once we plugged this n, we're actually going to get a pretty simple equation
something that only depends on T₀ and T₁.
To help you better visualize how are we going to fill in the array using loops,
I've created this diagram right here which color codes the different possible coefficients
that we could have in any slot in the matrix.
As you just saw, a bunch of the terms in the matrix are going to be 0,
so I filled in big 0s for those portions of the matrix.
We know that the temperature of the second that we're looking at,
is going to have a coefficient of 1+2C in front of it corresponding to this blue spirals.
We know that both adjacent segments who have coefficients of -C
which are these pink spirals over here.
The two exceptions of course occur at the boundaries,
for we have one pink spiral and one green spiral.
For one coefficient -C and then one coefficient of 1+C.
Now if I felt like working really hard, I guess I could have drawn this diagram
with 100 rows and 100 columns making up the actual size of the matrix that we're looking at.
But I was feeling lazy so I scaled it down a bit.
However, if we think about it, we know that the number of blue spirals
in that imaginary expanded diagram will be equal to 98 because there's going to be one blue spiral
in every row with the exception of the first and last.
Similarly, we would see 198 pink spirals, two for every row,
except only one in the top and bottom rows.
In the picture I just showed you, the blue spirals corresponded to the coefficient 1+2C
and we said that we would need a loop using 98 iterations to express that.
That's exactly what we have here in this top for loop.
You can see that the next for loop contains one more iteration, since it starts at the index 1 lower.
As expected, this corresponds to the pink spirals in the diagram with the coefficient equals -C.
Here we have two exceptions for the two different boundaries
and you remember that these were the green spirals in the diagram.
We can check and see that we've set the step size equal to 0.5 seconds as we said we want to do.
We can run the program and see what we get.
Sure enough, we end up with the same solution that I showed you earlier.
Since in our initial situation, we had a flame placed under the center of our wire,
it makes sense that after some time has passed,
we still see a peak in temperature toward the center of the wire,
but the distribution has smooth out quite a bit.
This has right in line that what we expect from the heat equation.
Right now, the end time is set to 10 seconds which means that the final graph that we're looking at
is the distribution of the temperature at this time.
Let's see what happens if we set it to something smaller
showing what's happening earlier on in the temperature change.
So here's our distribution after just 4 seconds have passed.
Consider we have a nice smooth curve, a lot like what we saw earlier
except that this time the peak is at a much higher level than it was earlier.
When end time was at the 10 seconds, the peak was just under 500 Kelvin
and now we can see that it's resting right above 600.
The distribution is also quite a bit narrower showing that we're farther away
from the equilibrium position than we were with the larger step.